[Musique]
tous ces huit peut-être un g5 elle est
vraiment mal autant maintenant anastasia
mettait un g5 vraiment pas l'envoyer à
un g5 pour chasser ce cavale j'ai peur
qu'elle perde autant une nouvelle fois
elle s'est mise trop mal autant elle
s'est mise vraiment trop mal autant ces
dommages assez dommage la pointe de
vitesse
elle va tomber
aïe catastrophe par anastasia difficile
on sent qu'elle est déçue on sent
qu'elle est déçue elle n'a pas elle n'a
pas pu faire parler la pointe de vitesse
l.perrin lyon tu mets cavaliers des
singes qui avait promis hier fou prend
des 5 à 4 ans et 7 qui menaçait cai
province est allé peut-être cavaliers
pros f6 aussi qui rôdent fou prend la f6
d'entourer un jouet
qu'est qui va venir e4 où pranger c'est
ça va jouer à la pendule 6 secondes pour
dd 5 secondes
oria dû tout reprendre cet as du
cavalier pro7 c'est une fourchette à
mais démentent et qui fait parler qui
fait parler la pointe de vitesse elle
s'entraînait pour la compétition ouais
ça va ça va faire tomber ça va faire du
sal ouais c'est dommage c'est dommage
elle alla secondes par coup et c'est
dommage c'est dommage pour anastasia qui
avait la game qui avait la game en main
par et c'est cruel assez cruel parce que
c'est ça ça mérite ça mérite vraiment
mieux ils voient pas le temps d'en bas
parce qu'également j'ai mon truc de
skate c'est pas normal mais je peux pas
t'aider
je veux te faire des habitants si tu
veux pendant je dirais je dirais oui la
joueuse la jeunesse iranienne n'a plus
que quelques secondes
je te ferai je te ferai un truc de
commentateurs attaques de thibaut pinot
la poursuite sur le silmo pineau
rattrapés par le peloton
c'est bon que tu sois sur le coup chute
à l'arrière chut je la corrigerai f4
bien louis dakhla tôt ouais et
maintenant peut-être revenir aux six
avec le fou pourrait bien jouer pour
faire d'un match 4 c'est bien là ce
qu'elle fait dames 1 scott très bien que
dans le dommage causé de lourdes à mach
4 3g injuste ouais ouais
allez un peu short il n'ya pas fois je
croyais à roye g1 je crois pas du coup
ça je suis ça doit être maintenant je ne
vois pas jouer comme ça et jouer seuls 4
attention je m'entoure ses rites ses
matons 8o elle était pas loin
ces dames province est ou non on ou non
au nom d'un prince est à yahia et
apprendre cette elle était dedans assez
dommage
après ça aurait pas été super mérité
mesdames province est je crois que ce
fiel l'avion d'un premier set après elle
a fait une tête c'est n'importe quoi
manger 4 jouer c'est bien je pense qu'il
faut qu'il joue pour beckett
c'est ça non non non c'est depuis quatre
mois oui non mais genre si tu joues pour
l anoci et claude près move il faut être
ok 6 et 6,5 c'est très bien joué ça
trois des cinq magasins bondés saint lô
non au nom au nom mathieu roy des cinq
sacs seul à temps c'est pas fait roi des
cinq marins
ouais ça c'est 6 et 7 6 5 et ça gagne
ah ben voilà mathieu enfin elle va nous
y est je t'annonce qu'elle reste clair
mat et rencontres il doit kg 5 peut
faire ton de l avais 0,2 sophie et h 3à
non non non olala au la cata voilà mais
ça fait deux quel choc l'un à elle veut
tourner france et 4 l attaque le
cavalier pour projet de bien jouer fou
pranger deux cavaliers de haut c'est
bien joué de la part de pauline lauret
l'après move cave a lieu 2 olalala est
là là elle a la réussite avec elle parce
qu'il a touché en maths
non
elle le voit pas non non pas maintenant
pas toi pauline au le tour géré matt aut
le tour j'ai un mac les amis pas
aujourd'hui pas maintenant pas après
tout ce que tu as fait je pense que
c'est ce qu'elle va faire elle a fait 4
à la pauline kee et ses cinq as a fait
mal aux cinq aussi est candidat à sandra
cas les blancs merde je raconte de la
merde je suis plus je me suis perdu je
me suis perdu heureusement qu'ils aiment
fait elle dans le tchat
désolé les gars ça devait bien finir par
arriver donc je raconter de la merde
depuis depuis le début 4 secondes contre
7 le plus rage 4 qui tombe ya plus de
pions il ya plus de pions quasiment pour
les blancs mais la tour qui va arriver
vers bessette j'ai l'impression qu'andré
a laissé passer sa chance
peut-être pas eu encore une tour qui
vient en c3 non la tour qui part en a
sept cavaliers quatre cavaliers des cinq
tours b un jouet tour ans elle part de
l'autre côté
au ls le pion à chaud n'en faut pas le
laisser celui-là non elle n'a pas laissé
maintenant il ya ce pion à tomber 3 5
fois côté h4 qui part h3 ça envoie de
partout f4 pour dévier le roi f3
peut-être pour ronan elle continue pas
la déviation
pauline qui domine vraiment peut-être
saphir sur une mule n'en pauline qui
joue la gagne
pauline qui jouait la gagne inquiet au
tour prend des trois c'est chaud c'est
chaud de nice les amis tour hk tour g3
maintenant le fou qui va tomber le fou
qui tombe et toi et tour matt en un
incroyable incroyable retournement de
situation les amis andrea qui revient
alors vous prend et fuite il alors
didonne cavalière scission problème si
ces dames g4 qui gagne
il ya une dame en l'air les gars
cavaliers fc sion prend dame g4 à faut
le voir moi j'ai la petite eva de l'ordi
pour m'aider sur les commentaires olala
ciel voix cavalière si on prend d'alger
4c égalisation ol à vue elle a vu les
avis incroyable l'égalisation est en
cours
oh la la la la légalisation les amis on
va être à 2 2 puis on s'est un peu plus
de quatre secondes pour pauline tour b 2
ça va échanger la tour qui rentre sur la
première rangée
ça semble quasiment perdant pour pour
pauline à présent cavaliers c3 et va
peut-être tour ces deux ans le retour
incroyable pion à 2 qui tombait en échec
à valider 8 2 échecs et france et si ça
prend le pion ya 7 qui tombe il ya tous
les pions noirs qui tombent les amis on
a sept secondes au le le clouage le
clouage et vu attention paroisse des
saints qui ont été hissés trois des cinq
échecs peut-être non elle n'a pas fait
mais des cinq traîne parce qu'on peut
pas prendre car il y avait le problème
de la fourchette le pion qui part quand
même le roi en difficulté le cavalier
qui vient en d1 le fou qui va repartir
vers à 7 le carel et qui peut venir en
e3 ça va échanger
non le cavalier qui va prendre f5 la
tour prends des cinq il ya très peu de
temps au temps pour f5 c'est fini
oh c'est fini les amis c'est fini c'est
gagné pour
pour andrea andrea qui gagne qui gagne
ce cet incroyable et victoire victoire
d'andrea dans le match incroyable les
amis il y avait tout recettes qui va
arriver qui va faire super mal non par
contre c'est la première fois qu'on voit
attend rien il ya quatre ans l'air à la
fin au le craquage
ah non ça va ça va elle avait prouvé
l'échec est en fait frapper chaque et
sarrasine casavant c'est chaud 1-0 pour
admira dans le set mathieu mais la
partie qui a tourné
des deux côtés il faut c4 ou la georgie
l'on perçoit 2 la série américaine
produite à la à la gueule
je sais pas comment elle peut jouer pour
le gain elle est mal autant je préviens
tu joues déjà c'est de tournage des six
voitures se consolident tout et essaye
et essayer de regagner un peu du temps à
la pendule
c'est déjà un petit roi g7 à un jeune
indonésien mais elle veut
contre-attaquer tous reprend dessins
qu'elle veut d'arrêt 3 je pense à m'y
attends quand j'ai cinq enfants des cinq
réfute l'idée c'est de must have et l'on
attend n'y a pas d'âme et froid la
tomate
mathieu c'est pas fini soit la suite
c'est pas mal joué en fait on a mis là
le module t'en prends des sanguines pour
les blancs nature vois tu te replaces
sur foot français sifflant les 8e de
finale croisés ça je disais qu elle
fatiguée pomme et la routière et la
police y ont été dures mathieu deux
ennemis deux ennemis masse et non mais
il va y avoir un an la vapeur d'arrêter
blanton je pense à cette attente en ce 7
juin apprend qu'elle est sain que catia
v6 ont été aidés par angers 5 h bon jeu
clair avec les 5 et prône aussi salée
ouais
ouah non elle n'a pas vu qu'elle prend
6,75 maintenant du coup pour les noirs
matthieu 5 secondes de carrillo cinq
échecs on bouge 3 bougez
il ya plus de casse pour le cavalier
mathieu au séminaire il n'est ce pas de
le prendre
maintenant tu menaces well as to hell à
tous elle a craqué mithra elle a craqué
quelque 4 victoires 2
dany rabon je retourne chez les joueuses
mathieu mais super match dames g3 leroy
qui par an padam g 3g 3 étonnant ce coup
g3a les fous et 4 dames f4 l échange et
les dames c'est dommage mais il ya peu
de temps pour sophie au nom coup franc
c'est 6 hall a raté deux fois trois fois
quatre fois la tour magique au la tour
magique qui tombe au les amis la tour
magique est tombé c'est incroyable oh
lola lola andrea qu'est ce qu'elle a
fait la tour magique on sueur haut la
tour magique d'andrea en sueur et ça
enchaîne tout de suite pourrait vous
nous racontiez des petites anecdotes sur
lui en équipe de france il faut attendre
qu'il soit dans le chat pour le voir un
peu rage et j'adore le voir rage et
quand on fait que de le chambrer mathieu
à un moment donné il avait une bonne
technique pour nous motiver
il nous disait il nous disait que si on
gagne et il nous faisait une petite
danse spéciale je veux pas je veux pas
je veux pas que vous sortiez les vidéos
quoi je crois que ça va partir en bas
[Rires]
alors quand on commence à comprendre
on commence à comprendre les secrets de
mathieu il va peut-être y avoir du g6
non h6 joué tour g63 pranger 5e set
attention le pion qui part en âge c'est
peut-être ya fou prend des six qui a été
ratée aussi au passage allrad fou prend
b6 elle rate fou prend b6 déjà deux ou
trois reprises maintenant il ya tourache
six échecs et h 8 dames au nom elle a
raté elle a raté tour h 6 h 8 ans était
elle était revenue dans la partie trois
jeux 6 h suite ça revenait la tour
magique qui a survécu
maintenant la tour qui va partir en
baissse est ici et le fou prend à 7
elle va le voir cette fois-ci auriez pas
mal d'erreurs
oh j'ai peur pour les joueuses là j'ai
super peur pour les joueuses d'un procès
trois fuites d'un français cette tour g8
peut-être nantes ou reprendre des trois
prises b8 hausse est bien jouer prise v8
et e7 est le pion qui file à dam a très
bien joué de la part
andrea et il n'y a pas de perpète elle a
raté elle a raté l'inratable allez faut
vraiment fait faut faire cavalier 8 ici
autour de 8 ans faut vraiment pêcher en
eau elle ne trouve pas caillage 5 et
tour f à 8
c'est fini c'est fini les amis alors là
le contre d'almira elle a raté elle a
raté un match quasiment d'aidé avec h7
et elle s'est fait contrer sur la cola
n'a olalalala c'est incroyable ça et du
coup tu parles combien de langues admira
5 normalement comprend beaucoup de je
comprends très bien les mains je n'ai
hélas demain l'espagne 1 mais j'étudie
le zinc absolument magnifique
j'ai envie de dire j'ai envie de dire à
peine nous nous nous là dans le chat on
parle minimum 8 9 langues
tu vois d'habitude c'est comme ça le
matin le matin en se levant tu vois on
on sait même plus dans quelle langue on
parle là cinq langues bon oui oui je
sais ça va jouer à la pendule électro
seconde actes et non la donne tout c'est
bien ben ouais mon voeu attend la lame
pierre parent ouais ouais ça lui a elle
été à deux dos la faire retourner ma
chérie c'est pas tout à fait du final
aucun super le nom genre à 4 à l'irak un
peu des galas cam va mais vite dame
prend tour c'est bien joué de la part
d'anne me ramène truc c'est que tu peux
jamais monté avec la tour mais tu peux
jamais tout soit on perd un rang regarde
elle a joué avec 0,01 non non non non
elle aura cette année 8 matin en voiture
en attendant pendant qu'on tape la
discute admire elle en train de faire le
taf
tu l'as bien procès bien fois elle est
en train de gagner un pion trop ku et là
elle a perdu qu on l a peut faire nul
avec dame bkb 3 elle fait pas ou là mais
s'il devait venir
mais en fait c'est l'état me katell
attend non tu peux me vois ces cinq d'un
français 4 comprend fou prend ou la
revue puisqu'elle fania
bug alabau guerre est elle fait tour c2l
la vue mettant ses deux ailes peut pas
le faire 18 les manants tournante on
pense à cette ascèse dans l'autre
l'ordre est et l'autre pour comprendre
des 8
bon c'est pas fait mature encore et ce
qu'elle nous a craqué complètement aux
incroyables
mathieu laças envoie des gaffes de
partout oh là là oh là là on devra qui
perd qui perd sur togaf énorme
ces deux prêts move voilà c'est cruel
bah écoute c'est toi c'est toi c'est toi
qui remporte le trophée almira et du
coup tu vas voir la petite émoticônes le
trophée soeur la petite émoticônes
[Musique]